[Musique]
combien y at-il de cadavres dans cet
étang à ton avis il y en ait dizaine ou
une centaine ou encore qu'il y ait des
témoins peu importe
tu peux me croire il n'y absolument
personne qui parlera voilà à quoi sert
le pouvoir
j'ai vu une sorte de monstre hideux
errer dans le palais du roi
puis savoir où se trouve mon père
je dois rencontrer le docteur sun will i
pour savoir ce qui est arrivé à un grand
malheur s'est produit ici et il arrivait
tous ces gens
les morts sont revenus à la filmer ils
sont devenus des monstres
ils vont bientôt se réveiller
messieurs
615 ou tombent la maladie se répandra
dans tout le pays nous tous pour agir
le prince héritier à la jeu les anéantir
et ans
jusqu'au dernier
combattre et vaincre ses démons
et le seul moyen de rétablir la justice
[Musique]
a toutes sauvées prix magnifique que
savez vous de vérité